the table shows the number of stores of
a popular us coffee chain from 2000 to
2006.
the number of stores recorded is the
number at the start of each year on
january 1st so in 2000 there's 1996
stores in 2005 6177 so on and so forth
determine a reasonable approximation for
the instantaneous rate of change for the
instantaneous rate of change in coffee
stores per year at the beginning of 2003
so we care about 2003 by taking the
average of two nearby secant slopes so
let's visualize this
so this right over here i've plotted all
of the points and let me make sure that
the axes are clear this horizontal axis
this is my t-axis that tells us the year
and then the vertical axis is the number
of stores and we can even say that it is
a function it is a function of time so
you see in the year 2000 there was
1996 stores 2003
4272 2003
let me do that in that blue color
4272 stores
now if you could imagine that they're
constantly adding stores you could even
imagine minute by minute they're adding
stores so this is just sampling what the
number of stores they had on january 1.
but if you were to really plot it as a
more continuous function it might look
something like this
my best to approximate it might be
more of some type of curve that looks
something like this
it looks something like this and i'm
once again i'm just approximating what
it might what it might actually look
like so when they're saying the
instantaneous rate of change in coffee
stores per year so this is the change
the instantaneous rate of change of
stores per time they're really saying
we need to approximate the slope of the
tangent line
in 2003 when time is 2003. so this the
tangent line might look something like
might look something like that i want to
draw it so you see that this line right
over here is tangent
now they say approximate we don't have
the information to figure out it exactly
but we have some data around it and we
can figure out the slopes of the secant
lines between this point and those
points and then we can take the average
of the slopes of the secant lines to
approximate the slope of this tangent
line so for example we could find the
slope of this secant line right over
here as we go from 2002 to 2003 and then
we can find the slope of this secant
line as we go from 2003 to 2004 and if
we average those that should be a pretty
good approximation for the instantaneous
rate of change in 2003. so let's do that
so the slope of this pink secant line as
we go from 2002
to 2003 that's going to be the number of
stores in 2003
2003 minus the number of stores in 2002
so that's the change in our number of
stores
over the change in years or the change
in time so this is going to be 2003
minus 2002
and so what is this going to be equal to
see in 2003 we have 4
272 stores in 2002 we have 3501
it's going to be that over well the
denominator is just 1. so this is going
to simplify to let's see i could do a
little bit of i can do a little bit of
math on the side here just so i don't
make a careless mistake minus 3501
2 minus 1 is 1. seven minus zero is
seven
forty two minus thirty five is seven so
this is equal to seven hundred and
seventy one so their average rate of
change from 2002 to 2003 was
771 stores per year
stores
per
stores per year now let's do the same
thing for this red secant line between
2003 and 2004. the slope of that secant
line is going to be the number of stores
in 2004
minus the number of stores in 2003
over
minus
2003 which is equal to let's see they
had five thousand two hundred and thirty
nine stores in two thousand and four
they have four thousand two hundred and
seventy two stores in two thousand and
three
and then only one year changes so two
thousand four minus two then three is
one so this is equal to i'll do the
subtraction problem up here so 5239
minus
4272.
so this let's see 9 minus 2 is 7.
let's see it looks like we're gonna have
to do a little bit of regrouping here so
let's say we take a we take one of the
thousands from the five thousand so it's
four and then that becomes ten hundreds
so this becomes
twelve hundred
and now let's take one of those hundreds
and gives it to the 10. so now this
becomes 1100 and give that 10 so then
this becomes
13. that we took 100 from here and that
made gave us 10
tens so now we're ready to subtract 13
minus seven is six 11 minus two is nine
and then four minus four is zero so it's
967 so this is equal to 967
stores per year stores per year so we
really just have to take the average of
this number and that number to
approximate the instantaneous rate of
change so let's do that so let's take
plus
771 and then we can divide by two so
let's actually figure it figure out what
that is so let me add 771 over here
seven plus one is eight
six plus seven is thirteen
is 13
and then 1 plus this is 17 right over
here and we're going to divide that by
2. so 2 goes into 1 738
1738 it goes into 17
8 times 8 times 2 is 16
subtract we get a 13 goes six times
12 subtract get an 18 goes nine times
and then we don't have any remainder
so 18
no remainder so our approximation for
the instantaneous rate of change for the
slope of our approximation for the slope
of this of the tangent line right over
here is
stores
per
year